Thank you. [inaudible]. Good
afternoon everyone. Good afternoon.
Thank you very much.
Rob also fall into for having us.
It's an honor to be in London,
although this way the gates to
me every time I visit London.
Thanks. Snack Lien.
Thank you for coming to,
how did you then become to work for
him within his company and how did your
family take your,
I suppose that the change in a 1994,
Mr Mandela became the first democratically
elected president in 1990 in,
in April of [inaudible] 1994
and in October of that year,
I applied for a job, um, in his, uh,
extended office and he had a few
ministers in his office and it was the,
one of the ministers,
uh,
it was a booth for a minister
without portfolio portfolio.
So I looked at the ad and I was only
driven by the fact that I needed a job
closer to my parents home because I was
still living with him at the age of 23,
which no child should do.
At the age of 23.
I was living with my parents and I
needed a job closer to home. So, um,
that was the one thing that was
attractive about the job that the union
buildings in which the president's
head office is situated,
was close to my parents home.
And secondly, uh, it all,
the job was also advertised that
you would do six months, um, uh,
duty in Pretoria,
which is the administrative capital.
It's about 20 miles I think from,
from, uh, from Johannesburg.
I'm not sure about miles and kilometers,
but I'm about 20 miles from Johannesburg.
And then you could spend six months there,
rest of the six months of the year
you could spend in gaped down.
Now you all know, if you know South
Africa, everyone knows about Cape Town.
And even as a young South African,
we all just want to go to Cape Town.
So the job was advertised
as part of a sessional duty,
uh, um, uh, office.
So you could spend six months of the
year in Pretoria and then when parliament
is in session in Cape Town, you would
spend the six months in Cape Town.
Those two things were the only things
that I was interested in when I applied
for the job in the ministry without
portfolio, I thought to myself, well,
because, um, these notebook
portfolio attached to this minister,
the job couldn't be too, too complicated.
Um, this man does it. I thought to myself,
this minister doesn't even have a job
because he doesn't have a portfolio.
So I thought to myself, I'm apply for the
job and see how it goes. And of course,
never thinking that I would
end up in Mr Mandela's office.
So I was invited for an interview in,
in the head office of the presidency
and during the interview, um,
I was still conversing with the HR people.
The door flung open in
this very flamboyant,
beautifully dressed black lady intake.
Uh,
her name was married and she was,
um,
the president's brought President Mandela
private secretary. At the time. Now,
if you don't believe in fate or destiny,
then the story will make you
believe in fate and destiny.
I sat in that office when Mary entered
and she really just physically burst into
the office without announcement and
interrupting us. And she just said,
I need an assistant and I need it right
now. And I don't care what color she is.
And I thought to myself, I'm your person.
You need someone, I need a job here.
You know, the two of us. I
mean, it's mean to be. And um,
do she lived, we never got introduced.
And I was never told who she was.
And often the interview that
called me and they said,
would you be interested in a job in
President Mandela private office?
And I thought to myself, private,
it sounds dangerous actually. Um,
I thought,
well,
I hope I'm never expected to go
to his house because now remember,
I'm still very afraid of this
person. I'm still, um, you know,
with the same conservative
mindset, I thought if I work
in a, in a bigger office,
I could just disappear. So private
office, um, you know, didn't sound right.
And so I said, is this job in the union
buildings in the, in the aid office?
Because I was trying to avoid to
go to a private office. They said,
GCA sits in the, in the
Union Buildings. I see. Um,
and would I be able to do
sessional duties? So six
months, Pretoria, six months,
Cape Town? They said, yes. I said,
I'm sold neighbor or asking questions
about how big is this private office?
Um, you know, who would I be working for?
Would I ever have to meet the president?
Never asking those questions.
It was just the logistics that might
seems to me and that was attractive to me.
And so I said yes.
And of course then I realized,
so I was the first day I started
my job in the union buildings,
I thought at first that
I made a big mistake.
I walked into this very stately office.
It's like 10 Downing Street and you walk
into this office and the door's open by
motion detector and um,
it's very stately inside and very
formal and you can hardly a pin drop.
And all this grand idea and um,
beautiful carpets and everything.
And then I made one or two people and
I thought, well, where's the raced?
Where's the other 200 people I'm expecting
to find there? And they said, no, no, no,
we are only five people in the
president's private office.
So for the first few weeks
in my job there, I would, um,
whenever I heard the president deriving,
I would just lock my door quickly,
my office door,
the door to my office and hide
because I thought we can even meet,
you know, we are just gonna meet this
person and you know, he's the president.
Now I also kind of feel
a shame, um, for, for,
for you know,
a birthdate and down understanding a
little bit more of course now of the
environment. Um, but I saw it, it's
just not proper that we even meet.
So I would really hide
for the first few weeks,
sister unleashing to go from
that to where you ended up. Um,
so the title of this book is,
Good Morning Mr Mandela,
but that came from a watershed moment,
didn't it?
So I know because I've read that book.
How did that happen?
Eh, yeah. So two weeks into the job, um,
I walked into Mary's office because
of course I was now employed by her.
I walked into the office to deliver
a pile of books or something.
And suddenly this group of people,
a crowd of people exited her office,
all men,
all of them dressed in dark suits.
They're wearing sunglasses indoors.
Um,
they have Yuring aids and they have
all this technology speaking to their
watches. And you realize that
this is like a body guards.
These are definitely the
stereotype bodyguards. And
immediately you think, well,
you realize, wow, these people are so
you need to behave in a different way.
Now don't make sudden movements.
And um,
then things started happening in slow
motion for me because this moment was so
important. Um, and from this
crowd of people emerged,
President Mandela,
the first democratically elected
black president of South Africa.
And that first thing I, of course I
see GM was good morning Mr Mandela.
And he extended his hand
to me and I thought, well,
what am I supposed to do now as an hour?
And you must remember I'm 23 years
of age. I'm young, I'm naive,
I'm stupid. I am, um, vulnerable,
extremely vulnerable store.
Um,
and these extending his hand to me
and I thought, you know, it's, it's,
it was like moments that I thought,
well,
should I run away and can I turn
around and run down this corridor?
And then I realize, well,
these people are all,
they're going to shoot you on this golf.
You're going to be blood every way.
Don't run,
you can't run.
And then the first thing you noticed when
you meet Nelson Mandela for the first
time was this incredible
kindness in his eyes. Um,
the sincerity of his smile
is infectious smile RVs.
And they looked at me, still waiting for
me to do something and I took his hand.
And throughout the conversation
he held my hand into a firm grip,
just holding onto it.
And then there was a pause.
You were saying something and there
was a pause and I realize why.
He just asked me something, but I,
I have no idea what he just asked.
And I had to ask him to repeat himself.
So I said, excuse me, Mr President.
So when he repeated himself, I realized
he was speaking to me in Africans,
my own, my home language
and the of the white people,
the language of the
oppressor in South Africa.
And I heard him say over the years
that when you speak to a man,
it goes to his head. But when you
speak to your man and his language,
it goes to his heart.
That's what he did that day by holding
onto my hand and speaking to me in
Afrikaans,
he destroyed my defenses immediately.
And the opened me up to
the rest of my life. Um,
that was the watershed moment for me
because I then found this person in front
of me. We stood there for
about seven minutes. Well,
it felt like two years, but,
um, he asked about my upbringing.
Luckily he didn't ask what I voted. Okay.
I, because I think that was what's going
to be the loss, but no, not really.
He asked about my family,
asked about their upbringing,
about my parents, you know,
everything, these, these, these,
uh, very unimportant things really.
And I felt respected for that moment,
standing there and I,
I felt undeserving because of the,
of course then I knew of
the history of South Africa,
what happened in my country.
And you feel immediately you feel
responsible because the person you find in
front of you is completely the opposite
of what you were taught to believe
about. This man. He's friendly, he's kind,
he's extremely caring in his,
just his personality.
So you know what women do
based in a situation like that.
Then we start crying as well,
still holding his end.
Now the DSR rolling down my face and
I try and answer whatever you had.
We was asking. And um, he,
he saw I was crying and then he put his
other hand on my shoulder and he said,
no, no, no, relax. You are overreacting.
Now of course he realized that I felt
responsible immediately and that I felt
sorry and that I, um, you know, I
was just overcome with emotion. And,
um, that moment really changed my entire
life because I walked away from that
meeting wanting to know more
what happened in my country,
why these things that I was told in
the media, in the church, my parents,
I had to question my own upbringing and
have very difficult conversations with
people asking,
why didn't you tell me?
Why did you only present one
side of the street to us? Um,
and um, they are, it was all started by
just that one moment with Mr Mandela.
Do we have any questions?
Okay. Going, I have loads.
Sure. So I might just, um, hi. Um,
you mentioned that this sort of role
job can kind of consumer life and your
life,
their life becomes your life.
Prior to you getting the first role,
what was your dream job or where
did you think he was going to be?
And do you ever regret not
pursuing that over? Wait, what now?
Thank you. Yes, I am at the age of 23.
I really just wanted a dye job,
you know,
something just to earn a little
money to buy my makeup. Um,
I had no real ambition at that point.
My father was a businessman and,
um, he was a logistics men manager,
um, at the South African breweries.
And he had a very, very effective, uh,
personal assistant.
And she really embraced me.
And I wanted to be as
organized and, and, and, um,
uh, the forming like Danny
who was the secretary.
So that was who I wanted to become.
I wanted to marry and I have three,
three children, three boys to be
specific. Um, but then, you know,
life happens,
something happens along the way.
You don't recognize these opportunities
when they come along. And I think it's,
um, as I said to your destiny
and fight played a role,
and this is the life
that was handed to me.
And I always said to people that when
you, when you talk of regret, um,
I look at Nelson Mandela's life and I
look at him spending 27 years in prison,
um, away from his family, away from life,
sacrificing release life so that I
could have the freedom of speech,
the freedom of movement,
the freedom of association today.
So who am I to talk about my sacrifices
in comparing my life to he's my
sacrifices. There was nothing,
there was really none.
I would do everything exactly the
same if I knew what I, what I,
what I do now, uh, 20, well,
25 years ago and um,
this seven,
7.5 billion people on the planet now.
Right.
And I am that one person
who had this opportunities.
How do I day talk about regret.
Thank you.
I Zelda and my mill fellow
South African and wouldn't
fabulous.
Um,
it was really interesting to listen
to you talking about your upbringing.
I mean I was born two weeks
before the sweater riots,
so I know about indoctrination
by state and my family,
uh, and by church more
than most actually. Um,
I was just wondering what is your
perspective on how racial attitudes have
changed for white people in South Africa
towards other races and particularly,
I Guess Afrikaners do you think we're
there? We have a long way to go.
And where do you see it going?
Thank you. And Yeah, I
always say to people,
and it feels like we
haven't made progress,
but we have my night lot of
progress in South Africa.
Look at me and change is possible and
we measure things maybe differently now
because of technology. Um, I think
in South Africa you will always have,
in any society across the world,
you will have buckets of racism.
People will just simply refuse to change,
not for any good reasoning,
but people who just don't
want to change that.
You always have that in any society.
South Africa specifically,
I think there's been
massive, massive, um, uh,
pro as far as racial
relationships and our concern,
the problem are either is that I heard
someone said that we live in the age of
smartphones and stupid
people. So, um, what people,
it's the age of instant gratification.
Um,
we don't listen to each other
anymore. Um, and, and, and you know,
that was one of [inaudible] strongest
characteristics was his ability to listen
to people and to listen with the intention
of really understanding what a person
is saying rather than listening with
the intention of, of responding.
And with smartphones and social
media these days, that's what we do.
We look at something and without
thinking or listening, we respond.
Because I do want most likes.
I do want to be the most famous
person or I do want to shame someone.
Public is a, that's who we
as a society has become. Um,
so when it comes to racial relations
in South Africa, you have this, um,
the radicals, and I'm sure you
know, I'm talking about, um,
we have the radicals on both white and
black side that it makes it a beer that
we haven't made progress or that we are
moving backwards. But you know what,
in all the years I have not found
the people on the street that,
so intolerant,
as you see in politicians,
people on the street in South Africa
are not intolerant people in the street,
one to live together. They want to bring
a work together to bring solutions.
So I do think we've made,
we've made great progress.
It's just that it appears because
things are so open and so transparent in
society because of,
of the Internet that it appears different.
Absolutely agree with you.
And especially when you see the newer,
younger generations and just how,
when you,
when you see them going out socializing
and just how comfortable they are living
in such a multicultural society.
Totally. Yeah. And I always say to people
that everywhere in the world, if you,
if you look at the uas and did I as
well, uh, you know, you have these,
this very intolerant, uh, um, uh,
atmosphere and um, it's always,
it's everywhere in the world.
It's not just America, it's not South
Africa, everywhere in the world. It's the,
it's the radicals shouting that makes us
all move back into a more conservative
societies are, I'd rather be blend
and say how I really feel. The, the,
the thing is that if you, if
you are serious about, um, the,
uh, righteousness and, and, and, and,
and equality and the freedoms that
people like Nelson Mandela fought for,
you need to shout louder,
um,
and not become the blend
society and the people,
the person who doesn't have an opinion
just because it's safer. Um, it's,
it's hard. And I myself had to learn
through social media or the hard lessons.
Um, but it is a powerful,
powerful tool for us.
And if you look at
Nelson Mandela's legacy,
he stood on the world stage and
then at times they will maybe 50,
50,000 people in a, in a stadium that
he addressed those days. We didn't,
they didn't have smartphones.
So the 50 people whose
opinion was confined to the
50,000 people in front of him
with the Internet today,
all of us in this room is on some form,
some form of, of, of social media.
If we all have a hundred
people to influence,
actually our power is much
bigger than it was. Um, uh,
those years, you know, and
we can reach more people.
So how do you choose to use that
responsibility, um, in this,
in this age of, of, of, of influence,
age of technology and use
it to build the bridges, do,
to promote tolerance,
to promote equality,
to promote the things that
we all know, um, you know,
makes the world a better place.
Thank you.
And thank you for your time today.
Both my parents are Palestinian,
so I'm sure you can imagine that this is
something that's also very close to my
heart. And I was wondering if you could
be miss speak a little bit about, um,
maybe Nelson Mandela,
if he ever spoke about forget
forgiveness from within or yeah.
How he could come,
come over this incident.
The things that happened
to him personally, uh, to
work with and integrate the,
you know,
these people who had done this to him
and in society as he was president.
Thank you. Yes. And you
know, Mr Mandela at, at, at,
I think about 10 years after
I started working for him, he,
he started this thing of saying that
he misses prison. I forgot what I said.
You can't say that. That's disgusting.
To say that you miss prison.
Don't repeat that. And then you said,
and it's not that he miss prison,
it's that he misses the opportunity
to think about things properly.
And he then said to me, I, I,
at another stage I see team when I
started knowing him quite well, I said,
you know what?
It's very unnatural of you not to hate,
not to have resentment and
not to want to have revenge.
And with me alongside you, you
know, just take the opportunity and,
and,
and I'm sure we can overcome this,
but be angry at me because it's
not natural that you are not angry.
You have to be angry at, at,
at white people specifically.
So I see it take it out on me. Um, we can
sing Kumbaya afterwards. Again, you know,
just, we can make up. Um,
but you have to get it out.
And then he would laugh at me and he
would say to me, I'm these no anger.
There's no resentment. Because he
realized that unless he worth did himself,
he could not take the country forward to,
unless he worth it,
his own anger and his own resentment.
Um,
he couldn't influence the
people around him. And he said,
it's much harder work to change yourself
than it is to change other people.
Um, so when it comes to
something like forgiveness,
when it comes to something like
reconciliation that made me realize that,
you know, in prison it took a lot
of time thinking about these things,
what is the best way forward I need is
really to work at oneself much harder.
Um, in forgiving you have to also
reconcile style with your own boss.
I am my wisdom through my life story,
I had to come to terms with the fact
that that is who I was and that is why I
can be so brutally honest about,
yes,
I was a racist when I
started working for him. Um,
but I've been through
this change and, and, and,
and we need to take the time to think of
ourselves in any situation and how do I
appear to other people rather than one
thing to preach to people how to behave.
Because we all know
how difficult it is to,
to change behavior. Um, if
you want to stop drinking,
stop swearing, stop smoking, stop,
whatever it is, we, it's difficult.
Um, yet we want to tell everyone around
us how to be a, it's, it's, it's um, uh,
behavior is like,
it's like fashion.
If I change my ba there other
people will follow. So, you know,
all of that made me realize that Mr
Mandela worked very hard at himself to
forgive.
And it's only because he did that,
that we had such a smooth transition in
South Africa because people follow these
example.
I am,
that's very brave of you to work on
herself and share this experience with us
also. Thank you so much for
that. Thank you very, very
much. So, one final question.
Um, what did you learn most
from President Nelson Mandela?
I think the lesson that stands out
nightly is to respect the respect people,
um,
irrespective of who they are and what
they represent and what they appear to me
to be. Um, without judgment. You know, um,
Mr Mandela always said that
if you question a person's
integrity without valid
reason, it could well be a
reflection of your own integrity.
And I often think of those things
and I always think of the person that
approaches me now stripping from all
those layers because that's what I learned
from Mr Mandela is strip
him from what he weighs.
He or she ways from the sexual
preference, from the wealthy state, this,
the appearance, all of that, the
ideology, they, they religion,
they conviction all of that politics,
strip the person and
connect with a human being.
And that is what made him such an
effective world leader as well,
is that he always was able to connect
to the humanity of a person above
ideology. Um, and I think
that speaks of respect and,
and if we can all just dry and do that,
recognizing the human being behind
every person that we, that we, um,
that we come across, then, um, you know,
that it makes the world a better place.
And I be witness to the fact that I
saw a person waking up every morning,
um, Nelson Mandela for
19 years. He decided,
and purposefully every single morning
he decided if I can change or if I can
touch one person's life today,
I can change the world.
You really believed in that individual
action. And if you now look at, well,
the street he did. So it's
enough bower. It wasn't very,
it was a super human being. He was
a Audrey human being like all of us,
but he made decisions and always choosing
the right thing. And, and, and, and,
and I think that kind of respect,
that kind of self respect as well.
Um, is, is the lesson that I
take away from my experience.
That's fascinating.
So it's been amazing having you.
Thank you so much for coming all the way
from South Africa to be with us today.
The book is available and you can buy it.
It's a great read.
I definitely recommend it.
It's available on Google play.